[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're free a race of noble boys
heroes noble warrior heroes I would
describe her is about us yeah she's a
badass before she gets her powers which
i think is an important part of this the
powers sort of exaggerated or enhanced
but was already innately in her yeah it
is really cool this cool opportunity to
watch Sam get to go back and create the
foundation for this character that we've
all like known and loved for so long
he's you know one of the best actors on
the planet and also like my family so
getting to work with him again was a
treat so you're not from around here
it's hard to explain I was cast like I
think it was about three years before we
started shooting spent a lot of time - I
downloaded the like Marvel app that has
like all of the comics on it and I just
read as much as I could before we
started shooting I mean I still feel
like I probably would not I shouldn't be
on any sort of like Marvel trivia team
but I know quite a bit oh it's great
yeah especially coming in at this like
beautiful time when it's the ten year
anniversary so getting to do things like
that cast photo I got to meet everybody
who is really surreal and cool people on
the Internet I like joking after the
release of the trailer of Avengers and
game before joking saying I can show you
they're saying who you thought was gonna
save the universe and there's Captain
Marvel and who is really going to do it
and that is the ant-man trust yes or no
it could be true I have no idea you know
wow that's tough so secretive I don't
even know about it I don't know what to
expect I usually just try to make things
and that I care about and then I don't
feel like I'm in control as to how
they're received or where they're taken
to so I'm curious to see what will come
from it it feels like I'm just like on
an on a journey that I don't know I
don't know where I'm going but you know
that's just like
[Music]
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany just an old message hey
everybody it's Charlie so I just found
an interview from Comic Con with brie
Larson talking about Avengers endgame
and Captain Marvel stuff so I figured to
do a breakdown this is a couple new
things about ant-man a couple of jokes
about them saving the universe there are
a couple things that she's being
misleading about but in general they do
try to keep actors in the dark as much
as possible but remember they've already
shot all of Avengers endgame so when
she's claiming like she doesn't know
what's going on she actually does know
what's going on in the scenes that she
shot but obviously she can't talk about
that so there a couple things that you
can glean from what she says about
avengers endgame we'll do a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Captain Marvel
moment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this she talks a
little bit about the background of her
character obviously Kara Danvers would
have to be a badass to be an Air Force
pilot they don't just let anybody climb
into the cockpit then she gets tied up
in the kree-skrull war they get into the
accident and she gets her powers and
things go from there there were a couple
confusing things that just happened in
the comics them changing her backstory
in advance of the movie or in
preparation for it to get people used to
the idea but then when we saw the
trailer the explanation that Annette
Bening is character gave us as to how
she became the Captain Marvel that we
see flying around on screen is very
different from what the comics told us
so right now just based on the trailer
footage unless they're being very
misleading about how she gets Kree DNA
infused into her and gets her special
powers it seems like when she gets into
her accident she's infused with power
and then the Kree from there when they
start to repair her body infuse her with
a bunch of Kree blood and Creed DNA
making her functionally half Kree on the
genetic level like she was originally in
the comics albeit through very different
means before they changed it she got in
half of Captain Marvel's DNA in the
explosion of the psyche magnetron in
because he had superpowers that meant
that she got them as well so until we
see some more evidence I'm assuming that
that part of the Captain Marvel trailer
isn't super misleading she talks a
little bit about the future of her
character
that gets into more of the Avengers in
the phase four plan now this is where
she gets a little misleading because she
definitely knows where they're headed
even if she doesn't know exactly what
the story is because when you sign for a
multi-picture deal they give you an idea
for what those movies are going to be
like if things work out we're gonna do X
Y Z so when she says she doesn't know
that she's really just talking about the
story like even though they probably
have ideas for where they could take
Captain Marvel sequels they're probably
not gonna lock themselves in to a lot of
plot until they release the Captain
Marvel movie to see how people react to
that there was a rumor a long time ago
that she's signed for some crazy seven
or eight picture deal I can't remember
what it was but if you remember in phase
one everyone except for samuel l.jackson
and robert downey jr. for the most part
the main Avengers signed six picture
deals so that was sort of the standard
for big New Avengers level characters
when they came into the universe what
that entails though is the solo movies
that they do the Avengers team ups and
any like really big crossovers say like
Hulk showing up during Thor Ragnarok
where he's in there for pretty much the
entire film
so brie Larson shut down this rumor that
was going around that she signed some
mega picture deal like there's no way I
signed for that many movies early theory
she signed for two Avengers films
including endgame in three Captain
Marvel films which would make an even
five movies maybe six like Tom Holland
signed for six movies with Sony when he
became spider-man and that included
three spider-man films and three other
appearances in Marvel films with Captain
America Civil War Avengers infinity war
than the last one being Avengers endgame
so if they want to get Tom Holland into
Avengers 5 whenever that happens in two
or three years he has to sign a new
contract with Sony who then has to sign
a new contract with Marvel we can talk
more about actors contracts and how many
more movies they have after avengers
endgame because there'll be so many
actors coming and so many actors going
there'll be a big question about what
the MCU is gonna look like going forward
the last real big Avengers endgame think
that she talks about is ant-man
and I do believe her when she says that
she doesn't have any idea whether or not
he might save the universe because she
probably did not have that many scenes
with him on set remember early on when
we got the post-credits scene with the
pager and then the ant-man the wasp
post-credits scene people had a lot of
theories that the quantum realm has
something to do with Captain Marvel not
being available for
all the Avengers stuff that's been
happening since phase one but then we
got the Captain Marvel trailer in
Annette Bening very clearly told her
that her powers would cause her to age
much more slowly which pretty much wiped
the board of any quantum realm Captain
Marvel theories that you may have had
like oh she just ages slowly like Thor
not quite as slowly as Thor but slow
enough so that she still looks like
she's in her 20s when she shows up
during Avengers endgame twenty years
later when she would normally be in her
40s if you haven't been following any of
the Avengers endgame rumors there's
obviously been a lot of people that have
shown up on reddit claiming to know
parts of the plot most of the rumors
point to her being involved in more to
the space-based plot during Avengers
endgame doing stuff with Thor as opposed
to stuff with ant-man who seems like he
spends most of his time with Captain
America or Iron Man or the both of them
like when they're walking around with
the be a are effing technology together
in those special wristbands so I'm just
not expecting Captain Marvel to spend a
lot of time on screen with ant-man aside
from like a couple really big scenes so
obviously there's gonna be a couple
really big battles they'll probably be
some sort of end tag where they're all
together hopefully big theory they pay
off Iron Man's wedding and that's how
you do your big crowd shot with
everybody and frame together I do like
the idea of the twist that ant-man is
critical to saving the universe because
of the abilities that he has in the
quantum realm but I don't think that
he's going to be important in the way
the Captain Marvel is important she's
more of a punch Thanos in the face kind
of important like she just gives off so
much energy damage that she's more
useful in a really big fight than she
would be in like a really careful
planning situation like ant-man we have
an ant-man style heist montage we need
to pull off involving the quantum realm
and jumping around between different
realities also possibly going back in
time that's the kind of stuff you use
ant-man for well let me know in the
comments how do you think the Captain
Marvel is important to fixing the
universe during Avengers end game and I
know there's a lot of questions about
the spider-man far from home trailer I
haven't heard any new rumors about it
dropping next week if anything happens I
will totally make a video about it there
might be a couple surprise teasers next
week because of the holiday as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see the videos when I post them
so no worries congratulations
Ronald hull Guin you're the giveaway
winner from my last big Marvel video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your detail
click here from my New Avengers and game
video and click here for my spider-man
into the spider-verse post-credit scene
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]